my personal background was I was always
working on AGI at open aai that was our
Northstar at Google when I was leading a
large models effort there we were really
thinking about how do we scale up these
underlying models and combine them with
the other things we need to do to get
smarter systems with ad Dept and we are
building a super commercial company with
a product that enterprises use but the
reason why we do this every day is
because we actually think this
particular path of building AI agents
that can do smarter and smarter things
for you at work that are interacting
with than learning from the world's best
knowledge workers and learning not just
how to read and write but the
consequences of doing things that have a
word is actually the critical path for
getting to generally intelligent systems
in uh sort of the most the most
predictable
way